and then the one that really knocked me
out of my chair was the pull of U.S
adults that said do you believe that the
founders of the United States are better
described as heroes or as villains and
four out of ten gen Z said villains
there's only one out of ten for Boomers
and that's interesting because that's
that's offense 250 years in the past
it's not even an assessment of the
current moment and there's that very
very strong negativity
why write another book about Generations
so my previous books were on one
generation a piece and a lot of it was
about the effects of technology and I
give talks on on teens and young adults
and people say but hasn't this
technology affected everybody and that
got me thinking and it realized of
course the answer is yes and there's all
kinds of other big cultural changes and
I thought it'd be great to look at all
of the living generations and see where
they are and how they're different
one of the first ones that you wrote was
generation me which was back in 2006.
given that you've been tracking my
generation for quite a while what are
your thoughts or what's the story of how
Millennials have done in your opinion
did your predictions come to light
you know in a little bit
um but not entirely
so
my prediction was one prediction was
that Millennials would find adulthood
somewhat challenging and I think that
has been borne out Millennials after all
were the ones who coined adulting as a
verb
um and certainly there's there's been
you know a good amount of negativity
um online from from Millennials about
you know many topics but Millennials
have actually done really really well
economically so there's this idea that
kind of started especially around the
Great Recession of Millennials being
broke and all knitting side gigs and
will be a first generation to not do as
well as their parents and so that was
one of the first things that I looked at
and found actually while Neils are
making more money than gen xers and
Boomers were at the same age
is there something different or
particularly unique about the behavior
and the views of gen Zed than the most
recent generation is it just a
step-by-step iteration continuation of
what came before or is there something
particularly different about this one
you know I I think there is because you
know if you look at a lot of the other
generational progressions say from
Boomers to gen xers to Millennials
around things like individualism it was
a pretty linear progression
but then something kind of broke between
Millennials and gen Z or igen as as I
call them
there is a just a really big increase in
teens starting to say they felt left out
they felt lonely they felt like they
couldn't do anything right they felt
like they weren't enjoying life and
those are classic symptoms of depression
this all started to rise with teens
around 2012 and those increases just
just kept going it's really the most
fundamental generational break I had
ever seen in decades you know of doing
this research it was just this very
sudden shift from self-confidence
to depression and from optimism from
Millennials to pessimism for Gen Z well
you mentioned before the fact that
Millennials can sometimes be victims
themselves a little bit and that there
was concerns about whether or not they
were going to do worse than their
parents and you know this adulting thing
which suggests that you've got this sort
of long life strategy where you're
becoming a an adult infant for maybe a
little bit longer than you should have
done how do we know that gen Z isn't
just yet another generation which the
one before it feels like is a complete
catastrophe but in however many years
time is going to flourish and it's going
to be another Millennial situation
and maybe that'll happen you know I
think there's a couple things I have
that has me worried
um and then one is that that increase in
depression has now spread up the age
scale to younger Millennials to 26 to 34
year olds they were actually doing
pretty well until about 2015 so a few
years later than we saw the big upticks
for teens so there's something going on
in the culture that is slowly creeping
up
um to affect a lot of people so that you
know I think is not a good sign the
other as we know from Clinical
Psychology that the younger you
experience your first episode of
depression the more likely it is to
reoccur later in life and with the rates
not being so high among gen Z if that's
concerning but even with that said sure
we don't know what the future is going
to bring in every way and it there they
could end up doing very well absolutely
what would you say is the story of
mental health across the generations
then yeah so it's it's kind of a complex
story so we start with the silent
generation so those are the generation
before the Boomers they actually look
very good in mental health compared to
the generation before them the greatest
Generation who fought World War II and
then the Boomers after them and these
are also people who are all older now
who uh went through the covid-19
pandemic who were the most vulnerable
and yet actually the best mental health
so that's where we start then with
Boomers mental health starts to look
worse
um across the board um days of of you
know feeling more more stressed and in
poor mental health suicide rates
everything and starts to look worse for
Boomers
um Gen X kind of continued the Boomer
Trends actually improved them a little
bit after as teens having a lot of
struggles with mental health in middle
age Gen X is actually done relatively
well
Millennials did really well as teens
very happy
optimistic but then that depression has
started to come for them as well
and then for Gen Z is where we see
unfortunately the most consistent
downturn with pretty much every
indicator depression self-harm suicide
everything
um going in the wrong direction
is it a challenge doing studies over
such a long period of time in different
environments with different people
potentially using different
methodologies longitudinally trying to
compare them all maybe across multiple
territories how accurate can you be with
the data for this sort of stuff yeah it
is definitely a challenge so what I've
tried to do in the book is rely on the
data sets that have been consistent for
the longest period of time
so there's a survey of 18 year olds in
the U.S that goes back to 1976 and has
used the exact same questions
there's a lot of poor mental health that
has measured that since 1993. there's
the General Social Survey which has
stuff on on politics and sexuality a lot
of other things it goes back to 1972
because you're right that's what you
have to to try to find is that data that
has been
consistently measured so you can make
those comparisons
the most concerning statistic that I've
seen which has been floating around the
internet for the last couple of months
the CDC found that nearly one in three
high school girls considered suicide in
2021 a 60 increase since 2011 more girls
also now report feeling so sad and
hopeless they couldn't engage in their
normal activities for at least two weeks
in the last year
why what's going on with this why is it
girls why is it not boys there's also a
liberal conservative split here what is
your reading of digging into all of the
data
so it is happening for boys as well
the increases in say depression and
suicide are not as large 14 boys as they
are for teen girls but they are
absolutely still there so we can't
ignore our boys you know in this
conversation
so that CDC data is just one data point
out of many that pretty much all show
the same pattern that
Teen Mental Health
started to get worse after about 2011.
that's when when that increase began to
happen
and it just kept going
and just for context teen depression
doubled between 2011 and 2019. in other
words before the pandemic so it's clear
the pandemic is not the original cause
um of these Trends they started more
than 10 years ago
so then we have to say okay what
happened in 2011 that then kept going
and reverberated across the decade that
had the biggest impact on teen's
day-to-day lives and it's clear that
that's new technology smartphones social
media
the end of 2012 was the first time the
majority of Americans owned a smartphone
it's also around the time that social
media use moved from optional to
virtually mandatory among teens also in
social media itself changed it's around
when Facebook bought Instagram for
example when you know the like button
showed up and the retweet button on on
Twitter all these things happen around
that same time period
and that's when teen Depression started
going up and it's it's not just the
phones it's not just social media it's
also that those had Ripple effects teens
also started spending less time with
their friends face to face around that
same time they also started spending
less time sleeping around that time and
those are both things that are likely
linked to that increased technology use
so that's not a good picture for mental
health when you are sitting in your room
alone scrolling through social media at
2 am
are there some types of screen time that
are worse than others
it looks like that's the case
so for example there's a big data set of
teens in the UK and
the link with depression is higher for
social media use than it is for TV time
or gaming
right that's interesting why do you
think that is what is unique about
social media that is causing that to
stand out
yeah I mean you know to be fair it's
spending too much time on anything is
usually not the best of ideas but social
media does have some unique qualities
so one is that its algorithms are
designed to keep people on those apps
for as long as possible and coming back
as often as possible because that's how
they make the most money
and teens are especially susceptible to
that because their self-control is just
not as developed
most adults have a hard time you know
putting down social media it it has that
quality to it
plus uh you know Facebook's own research
showed these big issues with body image
for teen girls and and young women on
Instagram everybody looks perfect
everybody's life is more glamorous
everybody is always on vacation on on
Facebook it distorts
reality you know we are comparing
ourselves to others but we're not
comparing ourselves to others you know
in real life we're comparing ourselves
to others the way they're presented on
social media which is which is Warped
and that's also not good for self-esteem
or for mental health
why is there a difference between boys
and girls
so I think one of the reasons one of the
reasons the increase has been you know
bigger for girls is that girls spend
more time on social media
and girls are more impacted by social
media so the link between depression and
Social Media use is stronger for girls
and for boys and probably because of a
lot of the body image issues that come
up also just the way teen girls in
particular relate to each other
it's often around you know emotions and
um Bullying happens with words rather
than physically more often and social
media is like a perfect storm for those
things yeah I've been doing a lot of
learning over the last couple of months
about intersexual competition the way
that female friendships work and this
very very highly attenuated
understanding of social groups
hierarchies Dynamics you know we always
think about men as being the
hierarchical status driven group but it
seems like both uh in terms of genetic
predisposition and in terms of behavior
females are much more socially attuned
they understand body language facial
expressions much more they use gossip as
Weapons rather than fists etc etc and
yeah I can see how a Quantified metric
of popularity essentially which is what
you could see social media as especially
if you're not using it for to be content
creator but just to kind of keep in
touch with your friends and see who's
popular and who's in and who's out
a girl I've never once been
um told off because I've unfollowed a
guy but it has happened a couple of
times because I've been following a girl
yeah and you're absolutely right I mean
popularity has always been really
important for teen girls and now it's
quantifiable how many followers do you
have how many likes did you get on that
post of yourself in a bikini I mean
that's the other thing you have to
really think about when it comes to this
I mean Instagram's a platform where
young women
and teen girls post pictures of
themselves
and ask people to comment
you're Outsourcing your sense of
self-worth to
the world to the internet how much of
this is present outside of the US you
mentioned that there was a study there
in the UK but I did see some stuff
online saying that the link between
social media and depression doesn't seem
to be quite so strong outside of the US
is that right
um not not that's not my understanding
of the literature
um plus we now have more and more data
on those mental health Trends over time
uh particularly for for loneliness but
also for self-harm and for depression
that particularly in English-speaking
countries it's very very consistent
pattern that depression loneliness start
to rise among teens after about 2012 and
keep going I mean the the pattern is
virtually identical to that in the
United States and for adolescent
loneliness we see it in 36 out of 37
countries around the world
is social media affecting each
generation or each age cohort
differently
I think so um you know I think the
impact on teens is is very clear and you
know arguably more more negative
um but with you know with mental health
issues starting to go up the age scale
it didn't used to be there was those any
increases in depression for 26 to 34
year olds and starting after about 2015
it started to spread to that group as
well
so maybe that's social media maybe
that's other other pressures it's I
think it's a more complex picture there
but there there is especially sense
you know the mid-2010s
just with cancel culture and
um on online culture and negative news
gets clicks it's just toxic soup you
know that we all seem to be living in
that I think is having an impact on
everybody
yeah one of the most interesting things
that I learned recently was the increase
of suicides in pretty much all age and
gender categories over the last few
years suicides for middle-aged white
males are five times that of teen girls
and they show a similar pattern as well
I think that the other highest group of
suicides is mid-20s Native American men
what do you think is going on there that
that can't be smartphones and social
media surely
right because you need depression
suicide any of these things are multiply
determined
really not the question I'm trying to
answer though I'm not trying to figure
out what are all of the causes of mental
health issues or suicide but why have
they increased
and at least in the U.S suicides among
middle-aged people are actually down
and they're up among young adults and
teens so they're starting to converge
even though yes you're right that is
generally where the suicide rate is the
highest it's starting to equalize oh in
terms of the trend how they're both
moving together yeah yeah that's that's
interesting okay so let's say that
you've got the the smartphone addiction
the use of social media all of the ways
that that gets interpreted by uh both
males and females even more so what else
is contributing to this I'm sure that as
you say this is contributing in a a
chunk of it but what else is going on
outside which is causing this Mental
Health crisis
so you mean for teens yes
well you know I think a lot of it is the
Ripple effects that yeah
that the way teen socializes has
fundamentally changed that it's moved
online
and then teens are spending less time
with each other face to face which is
much better for for mental health than
scrolling through social media you know
and they're also spending less time
sleeping that is also really bad
um for mental health huge links between
sleep and mental health outcomes so it's
it's like a perfect storm with
the way teens spend spend their time
outside of schools fundamentally shifted
and has shifted in a way that they're
spending more time on activities
that tend to lead to unhappiness and
depression and less time on activities
that are protective against mental
health issues yes so it's not just the
fact that you're using social media it
is what that time on social media
replaces so you're losing some of the
positives and then you're adding on some
of the negatives and you've called that
the ripple effect
yeah I mean that's that's how I think of
it that I mean it's sometimes I've I've
said that the technology is you know the
warm at the core of the Apple that it it
kind of all comes back to that that it
it ripples out from there and you know
that's also the theory that I talk about
a lot in in the new book is that
technology has all of these wide-ranging
effects that it's not just we use
different technology it's how has that
changed our behaviors how has that
changed our values that you know it's
just one example
technologically
developed times and societies tend to be
more individualistic more focused on the
self and less on others and what you get
from that is you know a mix of what's
sometimes considered good and bad you
get more equality but you also get more
disconnection
yeah you said that uh the drive is for
generational differences uh
individualism technology and a slow life
strategy what's the dynamic that's going
on there why is that important yeah so
technology is linked to individualism
because technology makes individualism
possible
um it makes it possible to live by
yourself and not depend on as many
people because we have all these
labor-saving devices and communication
and everything else and Technology also
leads to the life cycle slowing down
so at times and places when people live
longer and education takes longer to
finish people have more time
to grow up and more time to grow old so
the whole developmental trajectory from
infancy to old age has slowed down so
children are less independent
teenagers are less likely to do adult
things like get their driver's license
right away or have a paid job or go out
on dates young adults Mary later had
children later settle into their careers
later middle-aged people look and act
younger than their parents or
grandparents did so 50 is the new 40.
older people enjoy longer lives and
Better Health
so that's the slow life strategy it has
a huge impact on how each generation has
lived their lives leads to a lot of
misunderstandings you know the
grandparents are like why are my
Millennial grandkids not married yet but
this is something all the generations
have seen it has kept going for quite a
long time and you know my goal in the
book is to help Generations understand
each other better and I think
understanding the slow life strategy and
how that's played out is one big step in
that direction one of the things that I
become fascinated by over the last
couple of years has been behavioral
genetics and the level of heritability
of anxiety and depression is pretty high
but what we've seen is conditions of
anxiety and depression rates of that
increase a lot in the last 10 years how
do you square that Circle the fact that
we do have this massive biological
predisposition it is incredibly
heritable
and yet we've been able to almost beat
our genes in a bad way
um with with the last 10 years yeah
because there are environmental effects
so
um
in in the classroom
personality psychology is what is what I
teach so anxiety very similar to
neuroticism in the big five like a lot
of personality traits it's about 50
heritable well more accurately it
explains 50 of the variation you know in
a group of people that it's probably due
to to genetic heritability that still
leaves us 50 some of that's error in how
we're measuring it but I think it's it
speaks to just how big these
environmental changes are that there is
such a large genetic component yet we
have still seen these enormous changes
because yeah some some people
are going to maybe never be depressed in
any environment some people are going to
be depressed in any environment they're
in then there's a big middle group where
the environment is going to have an
impact and and it does and you know you
see this over time but you also see it
in um you know other cultural
comparisons so depression is virtually
unknown among the Amish and it's not
because they don't know where it is you
know what it is or that they don't get
treatment for it it's because their
sense of community and how tight-knit
they are in their sense of purpose is is
so strong and if anyone is feeling sad
they you know immediately get support
it's almost the opposite of an
individualistic
Society yeah I am I think one of the
most difficult things that people have
to swallow when they first learn about
behavioral genetics is the fact that a
good chunk of the outcomes that they're
going to get with their self-development
their personal progress is
um
predisposed in One Direction or another
that they they have constraints they
don't have unlimited degrees of freedom
which in a meritocratic society is
something that kind of feels
uncomfortable you know you want to be
able to be anything that you that you
can be and you want to be able you don't
want to feel like people are starting
off on different footings especially
with conversations about equity and
equality
but
this is one of those scenarios where you
actually think well
the fact that there's only 50 that
you have control over with your
depression and anxiety in an environment
that might be engendering more of that
is actually almost a prophylactic it's
kind of almost protective in this way if
you had control over 100 this would
allow the environment to rag you around
however much it wanted
yeah you know I I sometimes say this
when I when I give talks on this that if
new technology is the cause of this huge
rise and teen depression that might
actually be good news because we might
be able to do something about it because
we cannot change the genetics we were
born with we can't change what happened
to us in the past it would be really
hard to solve poverty or discrimination
overnight
but we can set some reasonable limits on
technology and maybe
solved at least try to solve this
problem and we might actually have an
impact what are some of your proposals
for how both people uses parents Etc
should try and protect themselves and do
this from it so there's two big things
so as individuals one thing that we can
do no phones in the bedroom overnight
yes we are from the same team Gene we
are from the same team yep and that you
know parents hear that and they're like
oh I can do that for my kids but I don't
know I think I have to have it I'm like
nope it's for you too and I mean just
just so many studies from sleep Labs we
notice that you're gonna get a better
night's sleep but most people have their
phone on their bedside table within Arm
Street some people even sleep with it
like it's a lover right so what people
say next is well but I have to have my
phone in my bedroom overnight because
it's my alarm clock to which I say I
have some advice for you buy an alarm
clock radio alarm clocks have been
around for like 100 years come on yes
you can buy that alarm clock on Amazon
on your phone and then put your phone
away and get a good night's sleep so
that's that's the number one that's what
individuals can do it's the research is
very strong on it and it's very
straightforward and relatively simple as
opposed to say you know how much time
should I spend on a screen that's a lot
harder
um so that's the first thing and then
you know as um
as a society and individual countries
and so on is to try to put some limits
particularly on social media
particularly for
children and young teens so for example
let's raise the minimum age for so
social media to 16 and actually do age
verification to enforce that let's let's
get it out of that age of you know the
12 to 15 year olds which is already such
a difficult time developmentally
let's get that social media out of that
equation
personally for me even for the people
that are skeptical about the link
between the social media use and the
current increases in teenage depression
and anxiety I don't understand I I'm
struggling to steal my case for this
makes teenagers lives fundamentally
better messaging apps fine things like
YouTube also seems to be fine for me but
when you're talking about Tick Tock
there is literally nothing coming out of
that app which is Expediting some Young
Person's development in the world it's
not showing them things around the world
which are going to expose them to new
ideas it is it it is the biggest waste
of time that I can think and I do
understand that I am now sounding like
the Boomers that probably were
criticizing whatever cartoon I was
watching on Nickelodeon when I was 13 or
14 years old but
I I I struggle to see why this isn't a
uh a policy and also when you think
about the fact that these Technologies
still are very new tenures to be able to
work out just what are the sort of
effects
um I don't know I I I would be in
support of a policy like that you
mentioned there that you are teaching in
the classroom so you have had experience
interacting with 18 year old Millennials
and 18 year old Zoomers what are the
differences that you have noticed
personally
yeah
um you know as you know I'm a data
person I I like relying on on what the
what the generation says about
themselves a lot more and that tends to
be you know what I emphasize in the
books
um but I have I have been teaching
undergraduates for uh quite a long time
since I was a grad student you know
myself in the in the 90s and I've been a
faculty member since 2001.
so
probably the biggest shifts are
um with with Millennials a lot more
self-confidence which has advantages
that you're more likely to raise their
hand in the classroom
also more likely to be entitled and say
things like
um I need to take the final late because
I'm going to Vegas for my birthday
really what is your boss going to say in
six months when you're like I can't do
the break presentation because I'm going
to Vegas for my birthday so yeah so that
type of that type of entitlement is much
less common among gen z
um but they they also you know downside
are much more reluctant to talk in class
but they're very nice they're very nice
they're very helpful they're very sweet
people
um they you know each each generation
has their strengths and weaknesses and
I'm obviously generalizing here and it's
obviously my one experience but that
does sort of fit the data that you see
self-esteem you know go down between
Millennials and and uh and gen Z and gen
Z is more likely to say that they really
want to help others
um why are young people much more
risk-averse than
yeah so that that's one of the things
that really that really surprised me in
looking at at gen Z is they they are
they're less likely to say they want to
take risks
um and there's a big culture around
safety
and not just physical safety but what
they call emotional safety so it's a
phrase I had never heard before I
started you know talking to a lot of
young adults and they don't just want to
be protected from physical dangers but
they often seem to want to be protected
from bad experiences and I can
understand that impulse but as many
people have observed that I can Veer
into just never being wanting to never
be uncomfortable
which isn't realistic and especially as
young adult you're thinking specially
say a university student
that's often how you learn
and having difficult discussions is
necessary sometimes when you're talking
about complex topics
what are some of the ways that this risk
aversion has shown up in Behavior
so gen Z's less likely to get into
physical fights with each other
they are less likely to get into car
accidents
um and then
there's around the kind of emotional
safety piece I think that is why there
has been the call for safe spaces why
there's been more of the disinvitations
of speakers
um but there's been much more of the
idea if you can't say that
of we can't even have that that person
come to campus uh you know that words
can hurt
so this really big focus on speech and
language as harmful or even violent and
that kind of the kind of concept creep
of of uh words like trauma
um and and hurt and violence
what's driving that
I think but part of it is you know
safety was hugely emphasized
with this generation when they were
young and they did not rebel against
that they embraced it
so you know expect teenagers and young
adults to rebel against a safety culture
and they really didn't you know they
they took it seriously and there were
lots of upsides to that that safety
culture so I think it comes from that
and then it of course also
comes from the way people are
interacting with each other online
because you know think about if you're
16 years old
um today
you know how are you more likely to be
hurt
um
often it's going to be online that's
where people are going to be nasty to
each other not to your face
and that's partially just the way the
medium Works be a little more aggressive
um verbally when they're Anonymous and
when they're not seeing the look on the
other person's face and that's what
online culture is and that's where so
many teens are spending so much of their
time now
why was there more of an emphasis on
safety and less of a pushback I I can't
work out I remember being told from my
parents you know we as every young
person is you they're concerned about
your health and your well-being
what changed yeah
you know it's it's it's it's hard to say
I mean I think there was there clearly
was a fundamental change though because
um
gen Z teens fight with their parents
less
than especially Gen X teens did at the
same age
so you know you think your parents are
like safety safety safety
um that did the rebelling against that
by by fighting about it and that just
just hasn't happened and I think it it
it's partially because they're they are
just don't they're not as likely to want
to say you know go and drive around and
do crazy things because they can do
crazy things online
um so I've got uh uh a bunch of
interesting uh cottage industry
obsessions at the moment and one of them
has been trying to work out why young
people are having less sex than ever
before yep um socio-sexuality uh
openness to new experiences risk
aversion
um all of this to me
seems to be driven uh by partly the
ripple effect I think which is what you
mentioned earlier on and it seems that
there are just so many other things that
are convenient and comfortable to do
that get in the way and the reason that
I like this is an explanation is that it
seems to cover so many of the different
bases that
each individual person can find in their
online use their own targeted version of
an anesthetic or an analgesic that will
be allow them to not need to go out into
the real world to face rejection from a
partner to deal with the discomfort of
making up and breaking up the risk of
having sex uh you know we are in a post
metoo world it's no surprise when was me
too 2013 something like that so 2018.
was it me too it's 2018. oh my God uh
anyway
my point being we have these things have
converged right they've all converged
together and it seems like
what a lot of people especially guys
that are the ones that will face the
most rejection women also face their own
massive security risks in the dating
Market but I think um
more frequent low-level rejection would
be something that is felt by men and if
you are in an environment and a society
which is more risk-averse which has
perhaps coddled and and coaxed young
people to not have to deal with these
sorts of things
stepping out and facing the fear of
approach anxiety and rejection and all
of that
um when you do have Tinder online porn
video games all of these things are
potential distractions what is your view
on the current approach of young people
to relationships Family Life casual sex
long-term marriage all of that
yeah I mean you know life isn't safe and
sex and relationships you know don't
feel safe either I mean describe for it
for young men and then for for young
women there's you know the fear of
sexual assault um there's also a lot of
complaints from young women that you
know young men watch so much porn they
think that's how real life sex is going
to be you know that's all all of all of
these things
um but it you know
those those certainly there are those
fears previous generations kind of
looked at those fears and said well
that's the price of doing business
and I think a lot of gen Z because they
have these Alternatives have said well
forget it you know because I have I have
there's all of these other things I I
can I can do you know for for a sexual
Outlet
um and I think that goes a long way
toward you know explaining you know
what's going on
um and not just as a sexual Outlet just
you know there's more things to do at 10
pm
now you know when there were three TV
channels it was all boring now you can
binge watch almost whatever you want on
Netflix or other platforms was slowly
distracting ourselves outside of human
nature
I think that's that's kind of true you
know and we're really seeing this in the
surveys with teens as well that the
number of teams you say want to get
married or at least want to have a
long-term partner has been was steady
since the 1970s until the transition
between Millennials and gen Z about 10
years ago that's when started to go down
same thing for saying that they're
likely to want to have children so I
think we're going to see really big
chefs in in family life as gen Z is of
childbearing age that the birth rate
might never come back up
and then probably the marriage rate is
May uh suffer as well that's another pet
Obsession of mine the birthright uh
Global birth rate declines but this is
global right you're looking at South
Korea 0.8 Japan I think just above One
China right down in the bottom of the
ones as well uh us is what 1.7 1.8
something like that also not
particularly good the UK Germany
absolutely ruined at the moment
um and yeah you know everyone remembers
the r naught number from covid you know
if it's above one for every person there
is more people giving more people but if
it's below one for birth rates or below
2.1 actually it's two yeah two point one
but yeah if you have the equivalent
which is there are fewer people having
fewer people which makes fewer people to
have fewer people and so on and so forth
right um I I spoke to someone
um that added another Wing into this
because I like that sort of demographic
explanation
um but
their uh point was that females are very
um easy to sort of have social contagion
and the mimetic nature to their behavior
and if motherhood is less seen it is
less inculcated in themselves so you
almost get in the same way that uh
Birthright Decline and demographic
collapse occurs in this kind of spread
out step by step way you also get an
equivalent here which is kind of like a
psychological uh contagion too that
spreads out well there's fewer mothers
around which means there are a few
mothers influencing young girls to
become mothers which means that they're
refuted all the way down yep yep yeah
yeah it builds on itself
um and you know it I think it's
especially to kind of guessing that it's
it's that uh you know we're not going to
see much of a turnaround because the
birthright really started to go down
with Millennials well Millennials as 18
year olds said yeah I want to have kids
gen Z isn't even saying it at 18.
have you seen The Tick Tock trend of
girl with the list do you know what this
is no
it's bad so I wrote a newsletter about
this a couple of weeks ago
um there was a girl who printed out on a
piece of paper 350 reasons as to why she
didn't want to have kids and it ranged
from everything from literally growing a
parasite inside of you to uh like
um vaginal prolapse and or all manner of
obscure uh complications that can occur
during during childbirth one of them was
not being able to wear cute heels as
much as I want and it was I think it
ended up she's printed it out so
visually it's a very very kind of
impressive and long
um but it it showed to me just how
much the individual their own Freedom
themselves is a priority it takes
precedent that you are pedestalizing
your own ability there was a recent
Street interview that just went up
yesterday using a ton of clips from my
channel
um which I really loved and a bunch of
uh women mostly being asked do you want
to have kids if not why not etc etc and
the answers I know that these Street
interviews get very heavily edited I'm
very I'm always hesitant of using these
as as evidence but you don't put words
in people's mouths these people are
saying it for themselves and it was
stuff like uh I go to music festivals
every weekend and uh if if that happens
that means that I can't I don't have
time for a kid
um I'm working on myself right now and I
don't feel ready oh how old are you I'm
38 and you know I
the evidence that I've seen from a
meta-analysis from Professor rinska
Kaiser says that 8 out of 10 women who
don't have children after they break
through the fertility window didn't
intend to not have children I wonder how
that's going to change that was 2011. so
you you know you're catching that tail
end I guess
um
I really wonder whether that's going to
change I wonder whether
the biological clock is basically going
to stop ticking for Gen Zed women in at
least psychologically when they look
back and think okay I'm now going to
spend the remainder of my life without
without children for the people that
like to throw around well it does
millions and millions of children that
need to be adopted in the USA there are
30 pairs of parents for every one child
that is available for adoption the
number of Hoops that you need to jump
through is unbelievably high so adoption
isn't some sort of Panacea to to this
you know the same as like why buy a new
dog when you can adopt from a home like
it's just the numbers aren't there to
support this
but
one of the other things that I don't
understand is
some of the claims that get made
and I think that this is indicative of
both my generation and the generation
coming after which is that we hate to be
wrong because being wrong on the
Internet is uh tantamount to Ego
destruction everybody's always been like
this but I think it's got even worse
recently if you ask people why it is
that they don't want to have kids
they'll say that it's due to income
but I know that you have some statistics
that show
if the problem was income even adjusted
for living even etc etc that's bollocks
so what what is the story of income over
the last couple of generations uh
comparatively yeah so first you know I
had to mention there's been several
recent polls of young adults who don't
have children
um and then asked those who said yeah I
don't want children why personal freedom
was almost always at at or near the top
of the list yeah exactly what what you
saw in these on the street interviews
um you know income certainly comes up
um but it's often you know not the
primary thing
um so yeah the story of of income is
interesting uh Millennial young adults
actually make more money than gen xers
and Boomers did it the same age uh
they're wealth building
um has also caught up uh that wasn't
true for a little bit there but it's now
caught up
so there is a little bit of Truth to the
income idea though because most of those
income gains have been from women
so you think about a heterosexual couple
and you know maybe the woman makes a
little less than the guy but they're
both making a good amount of money which
is why those numbers are so high you
know for for Millennials now
well if they both keep working full-time
then you have to pay for child care
child care has always been expensive and
is even more expensive now so there is
you know a little bit truth to it that
that is it's more challenging than the
old days when you know the old bad days
in a lot of ways when women were not
making hardly anything and so if they
quit their job the family wouldn't
really lose that much income yeah
yeah if you stayed home with the kids
um
so there's that but there's also some
economists have looked at the stat uh
they look in the U.S at counties that
had a lot of income growth well you
think okay it was income then you should
get a big increase in the birth rate in
those counties that had the big economic
growth it actually went completely the
other way the birth rate went down in
those counties that had the big economic
growth and they think it's because young
women were taking those career
opportunities instead of having kids so
plus there's a if if it took so much
income to have children why do people
who are lower income have more kids than
people with more income and they do so
the income explanation you know people
have priorities they make choices
um and yes you know certainly there are
big problems with housing and child care
and so on but it is not the only
explanation it's probably not the
primary one
I found that so fascinating uh there was
a study done recently looking at uh
lottery winners and if a man wins a
lottery it seems like he's more likely
to get married if a woman wins at the
lottery she's more likely to get
divorced and I I think that the
it seems like in a modern world where
you can be afforded all of the different
opportunities and experiences that can
be placed in front of you
there are lots of things to do and
having children seems basic just seems
boring it's like I don't want to do this
uh talking about the gender pay Gap and
the changes there one of the the
insights I got from you was Millennial
women's incomes are much higher than the
incomes of women of previous generations
as a result of both higher wages and
more hours worked in 2021 Millennial
women aged 35 to 44 made roughly twice
as much as Boomer women in 1980 and over
20 more than Gen X women in 2005 women
25 to 34 made similar gains men's
incomes have fallen since 1970. how it
would have fallen much I mean that's
that's the way it balances out women's
incomes have just gone way up there
aren't gone down by a little bit and you
average it out and what you get is
pretty solid incomes why do Millennials
still feel poor then
sorry this one is what we just described
that in heterosexual couples you're
going to get that challenge of okay is
somebody gonna quit or go part-time or
are we going to pay for the expense of
child care I think that's one one reason
um another reason that's often mentioned
is housing okay but housing is so much
more well those income statistics that
I've been talking about correct for
inflation and housing is one of the main
pieces of that inflation calculation
plus if you look at the data at least up
to 2020 afterwards got even harder but
up to 2020 Millennials homeownership
rate was very similar to gen xers and
Boomers of the same age it was last but
it was less by a couple of percentage
points it really wasn't as much and
given that more went to more Millennials
went to college that make sense that in
that 26 to 39 group that you might have
a little bit of tapering off but it's
really small you know you think given
the way people talk about it online that
it would be you know the homeownership
rate would be like half in Millennials
compared to Boomers and it's not
so I think that you know that
explanation falls apart a little bit
um I think a lot of it is the social
comparison that people do online
that you know it who goes on Twitter and
says my income is great my generation is
doing awesome that's not the norm it's
just not the way people you know discuss
these things online and the same thing
with news articles you know it's so
often this you know Boomers were the
ones who got are all successful which
isn't true either you know and then they
pull they pulled up the ladder after
they climbed up it so the Millennials
couldn't go up I mean that gets clicks
uh so I I I think I think there's this
again this toxicity and this kind of
negativity you know that have have
driven a lot of it and I think partially
it also got stuck because you know Great
Recession times Millennials were really
pummeled by that that is absolutely true
it's just that they roared back really
well
um say between about
2011 and 2019 in particular but even
during the Pandemic those incomes were
were doing very well for for people in
that Millennial age range even if it's
not as well as the people they follow
with blue ticks on Instagram uh showing
one of the really interesting Dynamics
I've just considered there is if women
of the primary Breadwinner in the
household and on average uh overall
household earnings are looking pretty
good
but the woman needs to take time off
work in order to raise the kid you are
taking a a larger hit a larger
proportion of the overall household
income is being exactly that's right
yeah and I think I think that that's one
of the big dilemmas
um and you know it's also something to
think about you know in in terms of of
uh of the birth rate because even though
you know you're honestly and on the same
page a lot of this is around personal
freedom there is an economic component
and that's what the economic component
is it's the challenge of child care so
um you know if you're going to
concentrate policy maybe that's where
the policy should be around Child Care
what's happening in education college
degrees and high school graduates
lumped together what's happening
uh you mean in terms of income no just
in terms of people completing college
degrees people completing High School
yeah it's it's really really amazing I
think we forget
that it was really only a few
Generations ago
say greatest Generation born in the
early 20th century where it wasn't even
really the norm to complete High School
many of them didn't
I was very very common and then very few
went to college
so with the silent generation those were
in 1925 to 1945 it started to become
much more common to finish high school
and go to college and then that kept
growing and it really really
um came to fruition with Millennials who
are the most college educated
of the generations that's probably why
their incomes are higher by the way
because they more of them did you know
get that college degree so
um you know that's that's just a really
huge change that the people forget about
about how large that has been
what about
the uh didn't didn't I see something
that the number of people
completing high school has dropped
recently aren't there more High School
Dropout people that aren't getting high
school diplomas
not that I know of I mean it now it's
possible that there were some weird
things going on in the pandemic yeah
that that might be what you're what
you're thinking of but at least up to
that point it had been absolutely in the
other direction that dropping out of um
High School uh was a lot less common for
say gen Z versus uh gen xers in the 90s
that you know the high school completion
rates used to hover you know in the 80s
and and now they're well into the the
upper 90s yeah one of the interesting
stats I learned from Richard Reeves last
year with his book of boys and men was
that seven times more males than females
dropped out of college during covet and
you know you've got this massive Retreat
this huge imbalance it's going to be two
to one females to males completing a
four-year us college degree by 2030
that's going to worsen the earning
potential down the line that's going to
worsen there
um imbalance within the home in terms of
who's contributing income which is going
to make having children even more of a
burden in terms of the Lost income from
the female uh
yeah it's uh A Perfect Storm
it is and you know maybe there will be
more men who are the stay-at-home parent
that's already happened but you know is
that is it ever going to be 50 50 a lot
of people have their doubts yeah I think
plug
there is people can be what they want
there are ways to have unconventional
household setups uh that that will work
out fantastically but on average
I think that women's attraction is going
to wane
if they have a man that isn't
contributing in the protector provider
role that typically that's what happens
this is more than just cultural
archetypes as far as I can see this is
genetic predisposition you know like
status accounts for an awful lot make
value isn't something that we just make
up it's mediated through culture for
sure but it is rooted in biology right
and and these things can be
bent maybe even a good amount but they
can't be broken and I do think that
there are some challenges there so what
about changes to approaches in Korea uh
the workplace younger employees why are
they different how are they different
yeah so you know the workplace changed a
lot of course you know with um
especially with virtual work
um that's starting to shift you know
post pandemic but you know I think the
the most interesting changes are are
with Gen Z you know the by my
calculations the oldest of gen Z are 28.
so they're not just new Young employees
at accounting firms they're now the new
Young employees at the law firms and you
know in medicine and in the faculty and
you know a lot lots of other professions
so you know I the most important thing
is the most simple do not assume your
young employees are millennials anymore
they're not in there and gen Z is
fundamentally different from from
Millennials but you know I we're gonna
see I think a lot of the things that
have come up on college campuses
are already in the workplace are gonna
even more so and I think that's what
we're already grappling with and we'll
continue to do so in the in the next few
years of
um are there going to be demands for
safe spaces
is
um everyone going to need to State their
pronouns not just in their email
signature but verbally you know and I I
don't think these things are all bad
there's some very you know good
practical things to to both of those but
a lot of older Generations are gonna
yeah wrestle with them I think that's a
good that's a good verb
um and then there's there's other things
you know we've already really seen so
one example I use in the book is just
how it has become so common
for University presidents to release
statements about political events
and I think that's also now why young
employees are demanding or asking that
CEOs release statements about a
political political events and CEOs are
kind of reluctant to do that they don't
want to alienate half of their customers
but then their young employees are
demanding it and they're caught between
a rock and a hard place I I don't think
that's going to go away oh so the person
is political but the professional is
also political now as well exactly very
interesting yeah have you seen uh maybe
getting out over my skesia have you seen
the newest season of South Park I have
not there is one episode that I implore
you to watch and in this episode Butters
gets a job at an ice cream parlor and
kotlin is jealous because Buddhist has a
job and it means that he's earning money
so Carmen decides that he'll ask about
us to get him a job but this Paul's a
favor and Carmen starts working there
within the first couple of minutes
Cartman says that he needs to take a
mental health break then he works from
home for the remainder of the day
because it's mindful Mondays and then
it's uh like work from home Wednesdays
and it's finish early Friday and it like
he keeps on needing to take a mental
health day and he's being overworked
then he tries to get Butters to work in
a Co-op thing with him because he says
why are we working for this owner he
doesn't even do anything meanwhile the
joke is obviously that Cartman hasn't
done anything at all or contributed to
it
um and yeah I it really hits the nail on
the head I think of of one of the
stereotypes that we have about this
industry or this this sort of current
generation of people who in Industry
don't want to work particularly hard
but then there also seems to be some
truth in this the fact that there are uh
increasing rates of of mental health
problems
um have you seen any data to do with uh
sick days Days taken on leave for mental
health absence stuff like that
yeah I haven't seen that but there there
are um some interesting questions you
know around this for you know what are
the the big surveys uh in the US of 18
year olds it's a great great place to
sample you know they're either going to
get a university or under the end of the
workplace uh and so things are on work
ethic like are you willing to work
overtime is a great example so that one
had actually been going up so it had
been on the decline for quite a long
time with you know from Boomers to gen
X's to Millennials younger people saying
uh that's not what I want to do I don't
really want to work that hard and I
don't want to work overtime and then
about 10 or 15 years ago it actually
started to come up you know with with
Gen Z started to be more likely to say
yeah you know I'm going to do that I'm
willing to work hard and then in 2021 it
went
just like a huge big Decline and who
knows maybe that's a blip I don't know
but that was also you know around the
time of the idea of The Quiet quitting
and the great resignation and yeah some
of some of these ideas of you know
somewhat real unrealistic ideas uh you
know why why should we have to work for
a living I don't know I don't think I
get this
um yeah that's kind of how it works are
you familiar with Nicholas abistat do
you know him
um I recognize the name yeah so he did
men without work and then he did men
without work a post covet Edition he was
on the show a couple of weeks ago
fascinating you would love his stuff I
think you you should really dig into it
um so there is this cohort of seven
million men aged 22 to 55 in the UK and
they are not in work and not looking for
work only 10 of them are students
they spend an average of 2 000 hours a
year per year Watching screens probably
video games half of that time is on
either prescription drugs or weed
one-third of them live in a household
which claims at least one uh disability
benefit
and yeah that you know hiding in low
unemployment data is this cohort of
prime working age men and when you
actually drill it down to it's that
particular group of that particular
gender of that particular age cohort
with these partic it's massive it's a
huge huge group of people uh and they
they have absolutely no desire to do it
and I put this episode out with Nicholas
and it performed really well on YouTube
and there were hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of comments from guys saying
you know why why should why should I
bother working you know that you know
the the the the world hasn't offered me
anything
um cost of living is so high that it's
easier to work from home or they would
say
um corporate employers don't value you
in any case so I don't need to do this
uh that because women uh too full of
themselves and because girls that are
four out of tens believe that they
should be getting with a millionaire
that there's no point in me even working
if girls don't give us the uh the
incentives to do it and it felt like a
fever dream if literally felt like a
fever dream reading this thing
and going
did it either I there's some very very
appropriate chat GPT bot has been
deployed on my YouTube channel all with
the same personality to try and control
me into believing in this is true or
I've managed to find a a cohort of these
guys that I
you know not not even work skeptical
work negative
um and I I it made me reflect I wrote
again another newsletter um
that reflected on a couple of
conversations one I had with David
Goggins who's this Navy SEAL hard guy
and Dana White uh the the president of
the UFC a video that I'd seen of him and
David Goggins looked me in the eyes a
couple of months ago when we were doing
this episode and he said it's so easy to
be great nowadays because most of the
world is weak and David Dana White says
to his to his kids uh if you are even
remotely a Savage you will run these
people over because nobody has any work
ethic at the moment and it really made
me reflect on those two things and I
understand that people don't want their
greatness to stand on the shoulders of a
failing Society right you don't want to
capitalize on what you feel like is
increasing fragility that is spreading
out around you
but for the people that listen to the
stuff that we're talking about today and
kind of Despair and think oh God you
know what what's going on yes
civilizationally this is a massive
problem but individually if you are the
sort of person that is concerned about
this you're probably not the sort of
person that is going to actually be
affected by it so what that means is
that the bar for greatness has never
ever ever been set lower
it is so easy to decide and and put
a five five percent of work in and a
tiny bit of talent and you are already
ahead of almost everybody else because
the bar is set so low so that was me
trying to turn a white pill out of um a
relatively negative a bunch of stats
that I'd learned at the same time
what a lot of people would answer to
that especially in the US is yeah but
it's so much harder to get into these
competitive colleges
which is true but more people are going
to college overall so you could argue
it's easier to get into college period
maybe
um but it you know it is it is true that
there is a lot of competition
more people to apply to the most
competitive places so I think that would
I I'm guessing if gen Z heard that that
would be their answer they'd be like
nope you know you're being delusional it
actually is more competitive and that's
what they have they have been heard
um and there there's some truth to that
but I I also do think it's true maybe in
particular getting to the workplace yeah
if if you're somebody who's really going
to put in that that that hard work that
maybe that is a little more unusual
we've got the stats on overtime you know
what I mean yeah like it's there in
front of you if you're able to work on
your mental health if you're able to
spend as much time off social media go
outside and touch some grass a little
bit that should be pretty protective and
again
the easiest thing to do to separate
yourself out from any group is to look
at what most other people are doing and
avoid those things that you know that
are negative toward them like it's not
hard does this mean that Elon Musk
tweeted about a year ago that I fell in
love with and it's this sort of um
traumatized illustration of a man with
sunken eyes and scraggly hair and he's
sort of looking down at the floor and he
says
um dear Lord why are you testing me so
much and then on the other side there's
this sort of Chad Jesus illustration
that says you literally need to put your
phone down and go outside
and it just makes me think like look
again the bar is set relatively low yes
these things are incredibly compelling
they're limbically hijacking they're
purpose built to try and get you to come
back variable schedule reward all of
that stuff right I I understand I have
my own problems with my mobile phone too
but just a tiny tiny little bit of
wrangling you know finding a group of
friends who also want to better
themselves to that also want to kind of
push back against comfort and
convenience and and ease and this isn't
to say that you need to live an
uncomfortable or inconvenient life but
that there are ways to do this so one of
the other elements that we haven't
spoken about yet but is a massive
contributor is political stances how has
that wobbled and waned over the last few
Generations
yeah so you know the really the biggest
overall change is just a lot more
polarization
and you see this among young adults to
the more identify on the extreme left or
the extreme right
and uh that there's in the in the US you
also get much more of an association
over the last few decades
um with being liberal and being Democrat
and being conservative and being
Republican people forget that that used
to not be as as Stark
uh and it's just become this environment
where it's not just oh I disagree with
that other party but I hate them
and not only I disagree with that other
person but I hate the person
and we're there um some people refer to
it to it as effective polarization
affect meaning emotion and that's what's
really stunning there's a big survey
that that's uh been done for decades and
decades and it asks people to say you
know on a temperature scale you know how
warm do you feel towards certain groups
and Democrats about Republicans or
Republicans about Democrats is in
frostbite territory now and it used to
be maybe oh mid-50s and now it's like
20.
um so there's just uh you know a lot of
negative feeling it's almost like it's
replaced religion
or you know even more
um you know something else where it's
just like that's the other
that's how we're dividing each other now
is is it's based on politics
a sort of study that showed one-third of
Democrats worry about their son or
daughter marrying a Republican
exact same thing yeah is it true so you
mentioned earlier on uh gen Z from
college coming into the workplace and
needing the CEO or president to comment
on current cultural events something
tells me that if you are conservative or
republican this is not going to be the
sort of thing that you're pushing
therefore does this suggest that gen Z
is more liberal that they are voting
more progressively
well young the younger Generations tend
to be more Progressive and older people
tend to be more conservative it's
the basic idea is that
when you're young you see the problems
in the world you want things to be
changed then you get to a certain age in
midlife where you say Hey you know
there's actually a lot of these things
have changed
that's enough we can stop there you know
so I think that that's part part of the
dynamic there
but you know people do
sometimes stereotype and think you know
all of gen Z is you know liberal and
Democrat and that's not the case you
know there's a good third of them who
voted for Trump
but
even the conservatives like Trump a
little bit less so there's there's some
generational break there's actually
probably one of the reasons why he lost
in in 2020 was that he lost the support
of more young conservatives is that
evidence to suggest that this aging out
of liberalism is happening more slowly
or less
you know that there's there's not and
it's you know it it the the one thing
we've we've kind of learned in the last
five years or so is a really cool paper
that uh made the case
that your politics are at least somewhat
shaped by who was president when you or
a teen and young adult and whether that
president was popular
so the Millennials who were young when
Obama was President a relatively popular
president
well probably this this data suggests
tiltmore liberal and Democrat their
whole lives
so then if you look at that for Gen Z
it's a little bit more it's a little
harder to predict because neither Trump
nor Biden said particularly great you
know popularity ratings
so it's a little harder to see you know
what what direction they're gonna go in
the future and it it is interesting
because although they are a very
Progressive generation across a lot of
social issues
they also in terms of their behaviors
are almost more conservative in an odd
way like they're less likely to drink
alcohol and have sex for example but
their views on a lot on most issues are
pretty Progressive on average
why are these young people so much more
negative about their country
I think that's one of the biggest
questions that we have to try to answer
and I think one possible explanation you
know obviously there's a lot of toxicity
online and it has a lot to do with it
but I think kind of the other piece of
the puzzle that has not been discussed
as much
is it this is another
Downstream effect
of more depression and mental health
issues because depression isn't just
about feeling it's not just about
emotions it's also about how you think
and how you think about things and by
definition depression means you view the
world in a negative light
so that's why there's more that's why
there's more pessimism
that's why there's the view of you know
everything is unfair
and thus we need to change things and
then the one that really knocked me out
of my chair was the poll
um of
um U.S adults that said
do you believe that the founders of the
United States are better described
as heroes or as villains
and four out of ten gen Z said villains
there's only one out of ten for Boomers
and that's interesting because that's
that's offense 250 years in the past you
know it's not even an assessment of the
current moment
and there's that very very strong
negativity and it's you know the other
items too you know things whether things
are fair or whether you know they should
be changed young adults much more likely
to say yeah you know we need to tear the
whole thing down and start over and
negative videos isn't always bad you
know we don't want people to have Rose
Colored Glasses and see if everything is
positive
but if that negativity is combined with
hopelessness and nihilism which it seems
to be
that's not good for a stable democracy
this is probably my least favorite part
about the internet at the moment I have
many things that I like about the
internet despite the fact that we've
been very critical today
um my least favorite part it took um a
conversation with my friend Michael
malice to actually give a word to it
it's so funny you know you spend all of
this time reflecting on things and
introspecting and oh I'm going to link
all of these different concepts together
and then you realize that something that
you thought was a an unbelievably
difficult web to put together already
existed and it had a word that you'd
learned since you were age 12 or
something and it was cynicism I realized
that the culture that I hate the most on
the Internet is cynicism that everything
sucks that everything's rubbish that
it's not going to get better that the
people who believe that it can get
better the ones that are actually the
problem they're the ones that did a
delusional or conspiratorial or have
been silverspooned or coddled or been
given unfair advantages in life and I
realized that that as far as I was
concerned was the worst trend that I was
seeing online
um so outside of the uh distaste and
negativity for Country uh is there
evidence that shows that there's a uh
how could you say like generalized
cynicism disorder that this is just
being spread out elsewhere too yeah yeah
so this is the thing you're describing
on the internet I call it the hellscape
narrative
you know and that's that's what you see
um and yeah things are worse than ever
are they really I don't know uh and yeah
in the survey data 18 year old is more
likely to say I don't have any hope for
the world I can't have hope given the
given the situation
um
locus of control become has become more
external meaning you know I don't think
there's anything I can really do about
it yeah things are so unfair all of
those have have have have spiked in the
last 10 years so drawing this back to my
current pet Obsession of the mating
crisis
um I see a lot of people doing that
externalizing in terms of locus of
control that it's because of whatever
that's out there all men are going uh
potential rapists and assaulters or all
women are too full of themselves or
whatever it might be
um
another
sort of
interesting I guess consideration there
too is the
cynicism and the negativity that we see
amongst young people is
it's almost like a self-fulfilling
prophecy that if they don't try to step
outside of whatever it is that they're
doing they give themselves proof that
the world is like that because if you
don't go and do something to change it
then what do you think's what's going to
happen The World Isn't just going to
deliver you change especially not to
just your life
um and again with the climate change
things something we were talking about
earlier on but with regards to having
kids
it's almost like some of the social
change movements that are happening are
used as excuses you know how many how
many gen Z is genuinely understand
anthropological impact on climate like
you really really understand what's
going on it it is incontrovertible that
humans have an impact on the climate but
let's talk about you know exactly how
much of a difference is it going to be
in Downstream etc etc I see so much
because I talk about the sort of
declining birth rates a good bit people
saying why it is
fully unethical to bring a child into
this world when it's already
overpopulated and we're destroying the
planet like you do understand that's
like just straight up antenatalism right
like it's just it's just the most
anti-natalist position that you can hold
and do you really think like if you
think that living on a planet that's got
too many people which we don't at the
moment is bad wait until you live on one
that's got too few wait until you live
on one that is trying to desperately
hold on to an embedded growth obligation
to continue the GDP to grow when the
population is dropping by 10 20 30 per
generation
wait until that happens and I'm like
screaming this from the rooftops
saying look how can you be focused on
climate change something that may
slightly inconvenience your great great
great great great granddaughter's life
if that isn't going to be born if you
don't have any kids and within the space
of
50 years within the space of 30 years
China's population is going to be halved
they're going to go from 1.2 billion to
650 million people Korea
is having a 96 Extinction rate over the
next hundred years for every 100 Koreans
that exist now there will be four
great-grandchildren
for every 100 Koreans there are four
great-grandchildren wow
climate the oppression in the world and
you just think like I've turned
into the Boomers I've turned into the
Boomers that I railed against for so
long listen to me I can hear it just
falling out of my paws
so I don't know I I
want to be able to Discount a lot of the
stuff that we've said today as you know
every generation rails against the one
that is coming next and says that it is
so on and so forth
I wonder whether there is such a thing
as such a difference of degree that it
becomes a difference of kind that it
almost locks in a uh a longer term
trajectory which is so much more
sub-optimal
that it almost stays a difference of
kind and there have been some difference
of kind things as well as difference of
degrees and intensities too
um
what what ways could you be wrong about
this stuff if you considered that
yeah I mean absolutely
um you know what what has really been
the kind of
Lifesaver of of that my whole career has
been I've tried to draw from these you
know big nasty representative data sets
often of young people and that you know
you're listening to what the generation
says about itself
not what older people's observations or
some tiny pocket of people are doing
that helps a lot
but things can change
it's very hard to predict the future
that's just the way it is so you know
does this mean that gen Z is going to be
negative their whole lives well I hope
not and I think there there are some
some positive signs I mean one thing is
that voter participation is way up among
young adults
so if you are hopeless and negative
that's pretty bad if you're negative but
then you vote and try to change the
things that you think need to be changed
that's a better outcome so that's where
I do have have some hope is that
political activism in this generation
um where I do have you know a little bit
of fear and bias maybe also just given
my my uh life stage is uh I would prefer
that we didn't completely overthrow the
government burn it all down and start
over
and I think there's a there's there are
a good number of um gen Z who do want to
do that
what are your predictions for the future
we've got you call them the the polar
generation or generation polar or gen a
generation Alpha coming through what do
you think is happening next yeah so we
don't have that much data yet on this
generation but this this is those born
2013 and later so yeah a lot of people
call them gen Alpha
um I call them polars after melting
polar ice caps and political
polarization so two things you know that
will be talked about and perhaps have an
impact on them
um you know we the the little data that
we do have
um is troubling a lot of childhood
obesity
um a lot less of playing outside and
exercise probably because of screens
so hopefully we can turn that around
um I'm I'm I'm less pessimistic about
the fact that you know a lot of them
went through the pandemic when they were
young because a lot of generations say
the silent generation went through the
Great Depression in World War II when
they were young and they turned out
pretty well so Generations can grow from
adversity what I'm afraid of is if they
get stuck with problems that they can't
get rid of
as children and teens and I have the
same worry about gen Z
especially if there is something
pathological perhaps about seeing
challenge as a negative as opposed to
something which is to be overcome you
can only really grow from it if you
decide to go through it as opposed to be
completely split in half by it uh Gene
this is really fascinating I really
appreciate your work where should people
go they want to keep up to date with the
things that you do what should they head
yeah you know so the the new book
Generations about all six living
American generations and uh
just tons of tons of data and
conclusions in there so my website is
Gene twangy.com so
j-e-j-e-a-n-t-w-e-n-g-e see after 90
minutes I can't even spell my own name
um but that has stuff about the books I
also have a frequently asked questions
about Generations
um stuff about speaking engagements and
all the good stuff Jane I really
appreciate you thank you thank you very
much what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
foreign